un grand merci
le Tour de France au Vélodrome national
de Saint-Quentin en Yvelines ce dimanche
23 juillet la structure qui accueillera
les épreuves de cyclisme sur piste aux
Jeux olympiques de 2024 recevait pour la
toute première fois le départ de la
dernière étape de la Grande Boucle on
voit que nous sommes en rendez-vous en
termes d'organisation en termes
d'accueil qu'il y a les équipes qui sont
là pour pouvoir organiser tout ce qui
s'est passé là c'est plus de 5 km de
barrière qui ont été posées c'est un
dossier épais rien que pour la ville de
Montigny le 45 cm d'épaisseur toutes les
toutes les procédures qu'il a fallu
faire pour pouvoir accueillir ce cet
événement donc oui une vraie
satisfaction aujourd'hui de voir que le
résultat est au rendez-vous c'est une
extraordinaire vitrine évidemment pour
50 ans de Yvelines pour territoire pour
les Yvelines en général pour son
savoir-faire pour la capacité qu'on nous
infrastructures d'accueillir de très
grands événements ici aujourd'hui
national pour l'occasion les
organisateurs ont vu grand pour ce
rendez-vous avec une présentation des
coureurs près de 4500 spectateurs sont
venus dans l'enceinte sportive pour voir
les cyclistes et le maillot jaune Jonas
Wingard the place to be et aujourd'hui
on a regardé dans le monde entier donc
c'est c'est un vrai vrai bel événement
international mondovision voilà pour 50
ans en Yvelines c'est magique
aujourd'hui des spectateurs venus de
toute la France et même du monde entier
dans la foule comme chaque année les
supporters colombiens mettent l'ambiance
c'est la passion c'est la passion du
cyclisme en Colombie qui fait ça qui
fait que les gens qui habitent à
différents pays qui arrivent en France
pour suivre les Tours de France et
soutenir l'école j'adore mon pays pour
les soutenir ou dans n'importe quel pays
qu'on est voilà on est fier de nous
champions le spectacle est également à
l'extérieur la fameuse caravane
publicitaire s'était installée entre
l'avenue du centre de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et le vélodrome
national ils sont hyper créatifs ils
font ils font des trucs de malade quoi
enfin là je sais pas ce que c'est si
c'est un quad mais c'est une sorte de
espresso machine donc non c'est plutôt
chouette je trouve que c'est très beau
et que ça vaut le coup de venir et on
s'en rend pas compte que c'est
gigantesque c'est vraiment très bien
une fois parti les caravaniers du Tour
de France distribue des cadeaux à
l'effigie des marques pour le plus grand
plaisir du public
on a les bagues on a des bonbons des
gâteaux et c'est génial pour les enfants
on est venu en famille on est venus pour
à récupérer les petits cadeaux c'est
génial à 16h40 le peu le ton s’était
lancé depuis le parvis du vélo de Rome
national de Saint-Quentin en Yvelines
devant des milliers de spectateurs
c'était impressionnant parce que les
voir comme ça quand on les voit sur la
route on a on les voit à peine alors que
là on a le temps de les voir un petit
peu mieux quoi on a eu la chance de
pouvoir super bien se placer on était
vraiment sur la ligne devant tous les
maillots distinctifs et ouais juste
simplement croiser le regard de Tibo
Pinot qui me fasse un petit signe voir
tous les coureurs juste à côté on était
placé parfaitement et c'est pas c'est
c'est le départ donc on reçoit on voit
pas grand-chose mais le moment le moment
est incroyable
les coureurs ont ensuite quitté les
Yvelines une heure plus tard après avoir
notamment traversé les villes de
Fontenay-le-Fleury d'Élancourt de
Guyancourt et de Versailles